[Music]
you're the Explorer even you can't don't
be afraid your dream to be in a forest I
wish to find a lost city
what you seek is far greater than you
ever imagined
your soul will never be quiet until you
find this place
it is your destiny
there's a major exploration afoot
terrible disease murderous savages the
journey may well mean your life don't go
you'll not know you when you return I
know this is a sacrifice for all of us
they won't be worth it a man's reach
should exceed his grasp I am proposing
it Amazonia contain a hidden
civilization if we may find a city where
one was considered impossible to exist
it's very well write a whole new chapter
in human history are you insisting that
these savages they're our equals their
civilization very well creator I call it
set the ultimate piece of the human
puzzle I strongly advise you to abort
the mission it's become far too
dangerous
must turn back there is no turning I
stay here and struggle to provide for
the children while you wonder the jungle
you don't care about us
you don't even care about their home
come on you care about your lost city
this search for Zed I can no longer bear
the cost
you've come to doubt its existence know
that only doubt that said provide all
the answers you seek from
all of us the environments brutally
difficult the journey may well mean your
life but you could reclaim your family
name ain't no buts